oh I do like a party come on babe what
should happen if you forget about me
silly unfair oh never forget about you
pay a promise Averell when I'm 100 we
should be working this weekend Robin but
I promised my wife and daughter I'd take
them away this weekend all hands on deck
you won't be coming to the cottage it
can't be helped your life is happening
now right in front of you what to do
what to do what to do what to do indeed
poor Christopher Robin
the tree I remember was in the
countryside not here in London there's
no opening I suppose it's where it needs
to be that's a silly explanation watch
thank you who why are you here oh yes I
need your help
I've lost all of my friends let's get to
the bottom of this look out poo
here I come oh it would appear that I am
stuck have you do stateand honey I have
not just eating I wonder which way I
always get to where I'm going by walking
away from where I have been don't you
that's the way I do a turn hello your
Christopher Robin that's you play there
it's gonna see if we can't find piglet
I've already stayed far too long hello
everyone so nice to see you all again
why shake you silly old bear I was wrong
about work I was wrong about everything
and I've got to get back to my family
farewell Christopher Robin
I would have liked it to go on for a
while longer
perhaps it's our turn to save
Christopher
you must be Madeleine wait you're the
bear of my father's drawings yes do you
know where he is I did you saw the most
preposterous impossible if anyone wants
to clap now is the time to do it I don't
remember being cheery people say nothing
is impossible but I do nothing every day
no kapu that's not never mind
you
you